the hardest years in the twentieth I
don't know who set the standard that
that's supposed to be the most fun
Amber Heard turns thirty next month and
she tells et why she's ready for the
milestone it's a big year it's an
exciting year great I'm actually I'm
really excited to be really excited to
be 30 I think I've I've lived enough
life in my 20s I'm looking forward to
this new kind of chapter if you want to
look at it the way I'm excited to be you
know even more of a woman that's what it
feels like
the actress weds Johnny Depp just over a
year ago but the couple keeps their
relationship as private as possible I
don't have social media but I understand
a lot of people do and why they would
you know a lot of people find ways to do
it for good and to control their
representations of themselves which are
I think actors typically or celebrities
typically not had control over
Amber's adderall diaries co-star James
Franco agrees why he'll become
incredibly conscious of preserving her
privacy as soon as people start wanting
to know everything about you what do we
get right and what's the biggest
misconception about you I don't know I
don't misconception I guess in a way
they don't really bother me anymore
because I've sort of accepted that my
public persona is something that is not
totally of my making and so I like that
it's a weird mystery these views play
right into the theme of their new movie
out April 15th what happens to us makes
us who we we tell ourselves stories
about our own past - I guess maybe
become the people that we want to be
anything
the truth